I remember a fellow common in the middle
of the road machine gun
Bounce has been hit straight in the head
standing next to me I remember all the
little youngsters like standing over his
body jumping over the bar
so let around my ways we had a lot of
gang activity red light G Street old
tree one hot spot
it was absolutely crazy going back to
like 2002 all the way to to the present
now I've nearly I've nearly been shot
about 20 times my brother got shot in
front of me five times
um I've had a bouncer shot in his head
while he was standing next to me this is
all on the same road on Wandsworth Road
I came from Peckham in a sense so coming
from Jamaica at the young age I was in
the sun started school in year eight
when I came over and from then I moved
to Peckham and growing up in Peckham
meeting friends and a son where I came
from I wouldn't say I came from a
poverty place or anything like that in
the sun because obviously had a good
family and my dad was kind of kind of
the same thing on the roads not just
crazy my dad's been in prison majority
of my life but one one thing I say like
I've never gone without you know like
birthdays Christmases I've always had
everything I wanted
but it's only as a Moulder it's my dad I
needed I need gifts I needed my dad BNA
you know for school for me
um I found it difficult I I was a guy
with no confidence so I was always that
quiet kid in class and if someone was to
make a joke with me I'd absolutely go
mentor
so I remember
um we was playing for a football team
and uh
no one didn't really like the football
manager
and um someone's done the football
manager in the back of the head with
something and that is the first time
I've ever been nicked for anything so
I've got Nick for gbh when I was 14
years old I took to balamuth court
and um there's a few witnesses there in
it they saw they said that it wasn't me
who'd done it so um that was my first
ever
thing I've got a Nick for and obviously
they found me not guilty
um after that I started selling drugs
I got nicked when I was
I've gotten it for a few times for like
10 pound and 20 pound drawers here and
there it's not until I've got to 18.
I've got NYX for a robbery in streatham
cash and Transit I remember this guy
into the train station to fill up the
cash machine
followed him in there
and then I just grabbed the cassette but
this year do you remember when like the
London Tube bombings were going off the
buses all the train stations are on high
alert so as I grabbed the cassette
there's already on police in this train
station in streatham I've grabbed it
looks I was like oh my god I've had to
throw the cassette back at the police
run got to the Gateway Vehicle
my driver wasn't in the car he was on
the other side of the road having a piss
so I've had the key I run straight past
the car got nicked at the end of the
road behind Caesar's Instagram that long
road there I got nicked at the end of
the road yeah for me for me like I got
arrested for um Robbie when I was in
school
and then there was a group of us and
someone obviously robbed someone and
because of what I was wearing I was
distinctive you know something I
wouldn't say I don't know what was going
on I used to sell weed here and there
you understand but it was not until
my mom you know something she didn't
realize what was going on so for me I
think I was about what 13 14 from drugs
to knife from knife the guns you know
something it was actually crazy because
it become a thing like we wasn't
actually out there trying to
put people down or you know something to
hurt people but it was more
The Defenders instead of the oppressors
in a sense so we wasn't that my from my
friend though Rob people whatever but
then we had to deal with the backlash
and sometimes it was It was kind of
hectic the life that man's always
involved in shooting star beings that it
was crazy I actually enjoyed it I used
to sit in my front room I used to do it
like I get a box of weed and pull it all
in 10 pound and 20 pound drawers and
I'll watch like a boxer I remember
watching Lord of the Rings the trilogy
yeah I sat there for the whole day
watching the whole thing just bagging up
weed
I used to enjoy it I used to have two
gates in my door on my house I have one
there then my door and then like a
mirror behind I have another gate so
when people come back and just open the
door yeah they can't get that I remember
my house getting raided one time
the police have got the angle grinder I
was like oh guys so I've opened the
doors that you're right mate and I shot
again because I know they've got to get
through that door that door and that
door if I did this time I'm just putting
everything down the toilet and stuff I'm
like you know
I was in a little Pub on Wandsworth Road
this is the same place where my brother
got shot
um standing outside I remember a fella
coming in the middle of the road machine
gun
Bounce has been hit straight in the head
standing next to me I remember all the
little youngsters like standing over his
body jumping over the bar and you're
like smart these things started getting
it was happening regular so when I hear
that someone's died now I'm like okay
like it it's just it's coming like it's
normal for me you know yeah and that
that's probably the worst thing I've
witnessed other than that my brother
being shot and had to cover up all the
holes on his back and stuff
it looks like in the daylight yeah so
that that one was in the evening we used
to have a pub there called the sw8 bar
it's the same place where my brother got
shot he pulled up in the motorbike back
back
he got hit five times my other power got
hit five times
the thing is I was standing right in
front of him so they're behind me so I
was only skinny at the time so if I got
hit with them five I'm gonna be dead
because my brother was about 70 and
stone at the time so he took all the
shots from hitting me I remember getting
to the bottom of this little ramp I'm
already on the phone to the ambulance
because I think my brother's dead
I mean yeah my brother's dead can you
come and pick him up
like I wasn't even thinking that's what
I said I'd put a phone I said where he
was sw8 bar put the phone down
I remember the motorbike drove off then
I ran back up he'll pull my brother's
clothes off it's like covering up the
holes oh please come then the ambulance
come
um I knew my brother was all right when
he said oh can you take the money out my
pocket because he had a couple could in
his pocket so I knew he was going to be
all right and he was I think he was in
hospital for about a week yeah for me
I'm not gonna lie like when I was in
active involved like I don't I didn't
care if I know I got my machine I didn't
care you know something then
getting links buying big you know some
big machine guns and then having things
in silences and it was just kind of like
for me you're just like right like did
you see this on TV
it's like yeah it's exciting and that
but like I said the times in the Sun
that people are getting and what them
kind of thing is doing and I thought
it's crazy because
it's always something like this here you
might go for someone and
trying to shoot after this person could
be the other person the innocent person
end up getting you know something to you
and that's how it was that's how mad it
is like all of my friends were doing
like 30 Rex and that
I'm not saying it as them I don't know
who done it or wherever like it was
someone who has nothing to do with any
gangs or any estate it's always like a
random person getting hit
was there anything you would never do
crime-wise
was there a limit
no there was no limit there is no limit
um there was no one telling me no
um I remember getting out the car
stuck the gun to the geez's head you
know just to get the cash yourself here
I'm thinking he's just going to give it
up like they're insured for this money I
start the gun to him
my man has swung a punch from me
so I've had to round it and I've gone
back to him about eight times but you
know when like you got tunnel vision you
don't realize how much times you've hit
someone I've knocked all this geez's
teeth out and he's laid out on the floor
so that one's kind of stuck for me
because I just remember like bits of
blood just coming out every time I hit
him
so that that's what that's actually what
I went prison for what I received the 17
years for
Ryan what did get you into prison what
was what was the one
when I got into prison yeah which one
did
um the Firearms when I got nicked um
basically find a car full of stash of
firearms
and that went on the news
and then they started I was on the run
for like three months in the Sun
yeah this is the day I got arrested as
we're driving
he's following my instructions so I said
take the rights took the right pick the
left quick you know something so then a
car come and I'm like
but as I'm watching everything in a
minute I'm watching everything in the
mirror and I was I'm not something I see
yeah the phone and we're driving and
then the bike came I said no that bike's
following us in the sun it was a CBR
1000 and he's like no man he's not
following us it's some red bike and I
said take the right so has he taking it
right yeah
at the traffic light in some sense you
can't go you left yes I'm saying to you
so I sit and turn you know he's turned
back to the main road so as he turned
the bike stopped in the sunlight they
stopped they couldn't turn so I said
yeah content yeah yeah yes I said yeah
definitely so as we're driving our cars
are coming and sometimes I'm still I'm
still tempted to drive you know we got
around to Ellsbury State I mean E Street
Market so I said to myself I can jump
out the car now and run into the market
I'm gone so I said no I don't wanna I
don't want to run
so I said I want to know what they got
on me yes I'm saying because I'm saying
if I can fight the case I'll fight the
case and I stayed in the car all I can
see is free cars back to back this is
coming fast I'm saying right I can see
the hats on as well and I say okay
so they jumped out and I shut the tires
out and I'm sitting in the van they shut
the tires out yes the tires are sitting
in the van and I'm like I'm like this
I've done really did what I need to do
with my virgin's phone so I'm saying raw
they said ah open the door I said I'm
not touching nothing in the sun I said
I'm not open up no door so they're
trying to smash the window my window
wouldn't smash so they smashed my
friends when they dragged him out yes
I'm saying to you then after that they
open my door drag me out and that was it
so when I got arrested it's like
they wanted to shoot man in a Sunday and
it's not even a joke that's why I didn't
that's what I said that was their excuse
me to bust the window yeah because
obviously because of the seriousness of
the um thing that I got arrested for
because there was like four guns in it
at the time and I can't remember how
much
um
bullets there was there was loads though
and there was drugs in the car as well
so
they wasn't even caring about anything
else apart from yeah we've got him we've
got him
uh prison for me
um if we're going all the way back to
like felt on days about 2005 remember
landed on induction wing
and I remember there's this fellow days
just look at him and I was thinking what
does this guy want anyway it's gone like
three days and this guy overheard him
talking he's like right that's that's my
man's brother
we've ended up having a fight over the
pool table
um that was my first like fight in
prison and then from Thornton went to
Portland where it was a bit a bit rough
like I had a fight I had a couple fights
in Portland that was probably the
roughest job as a while
I remember some fellas stabbed me on
free floor
ended up having a little fire fell on
the floor of each other got stopped went
blocking all of that
um it's not until when adult prisons
where it started getting a lot more
relaxed um no one really had much of a
point to proof yeah but now they started
doing mixing gels in it so you got like
um 18 year olds with 20 with 21 year
olds and adults and stuff now so there's
still the youngsters with little egos
and that trying to prove things and I I
got approached a couple times when I was
in high Dawn
um I was a lump back then didn't it so
no one really wanted to fight me
physically it's all like oh there's my
around like it was a little nurse that's
like coming in let's have a fight and or
whatever because I don't mind I was
quite good at fighting it depends on
this it depends as well you know who you
are when you go to prison because
sometimes you go to when I stand when
you go to prison there's a lot of people
you're gonna know there I mean a lot of
people so it depends who you are and
depends who you come across so life can
be easy going into certain prison
because soon as you go there because
even when I was in prison
understand after that time obviously
settling down
anyone that came in I was making sure
they're all right even if I don't know
them I was making you got food you got
you know sometimes I'm always trying to
cater for people some prison it could be
easy some prison could be hard you know
sometimes because remember some people
don't have money and sometimes to make a
phone call you understand you have to
wait a week to kill your friends get
your full credit on to do this so the
system becomes
nothing like right now people end up
going to have phones and content store
people want to keep in contact with
their kids like for me I wanted to keep
I want to tell my son good night every
night remember I was being shipped out
of ones with I had had my little my
phone messed up my friends like this
banquet so I wrapped up and clean form I
thought I'm violating myself I can't do
this man but you know what I found hard
in prison you know I always looked after
my friends looked after me with money so
I always had everything but I swear and
I see people with nothing in their souls
that used to hurt me and that's one
thing I'd say when when people do go to
prison they rely on a lot of family
members and friends to send them money
and that's a lot of stress on them yeah
because they don't know what the
family's going through at the time when
I first in prison my mom sent me a
hundred pound and I thought my mom I
said don't you ever in your life ever do
that again yeah and she's like well I
know I said Mom if you want money I'll
send you money yes I said don't ever you
do that again you know what I'm saying
to you you learn to manage your money
you know you know like when we say like
clean the wings we just get like 11
pounds a week so you put like five pound
on your phone credit you'll probably buy
a few tins of mackerel to whip up in the
kettle
like you learn to really um live basic
that's one thing I I appreciate about
prison I know I tell you basic Arts I'm
still eating tins of tuna or macro and
I've still got the same diet and stuff I
actually enjoy my tuna and crackers
every day like you know you know what
the worst thing is there's so much
talented people in prison here you would
never believe it
when I went to prison my son was like
three years old gone to before so being
in his life
in the Sun for the last three years
before I went to prison I felt I had a
responsibility and some tainted so when
that time came and I end up in prison it
hit me to kind of realized that right
like I grew up you know something about
my dad half of obviously my life and now
my son's going through the same pattern
in some scientists so yeah what I tried
to do I tried to kind of do as much as I
can from inside to kind of keep him on
the straight and narrow path and to this
day he understand he's been on the
street and narrow path and and it's good
for us to be here right now to kind of
speak and so people can understand where
we come from you know something didn't
try to steer them away from what we've
obviously yeah
derail from society so there's no
winners in this crime thing you know
when people lose in their lives like
being stabbed or shot you've got people
losing their lives you've got people
getting 30-year sentences there's no
winners in this like it's tiring that
I've grown up in this it's absolutely
tiring I've got a 17 year sentence for
um armed robbery I left a two-year-old
girl
I come out to 11 year old girl with mad
attitude and I blame I blame myself for
that a little bit but mate uh first
we'll see you on our first visit we had
she come when she was leaving
on the visit she's like you come home
now Daddy
imagine being stuck on a visit table
knowing you can't leave the doors and
you've got a two-year-old beautiful
little girl saying you come home now
Daddy
and you've got a lie I got I had to hold
the tears I had to hold the lamp
to disturb get goosebumps about it
um you've got to realize we're effective
we affected a lot of people going in
prison then because you have to think of
it like this here even though we're
doing our sins it's not just us that you
know it's a ripple effect so our family
had to go through a lot If I Could Turn
Back Time
I would you know something because
obviously now I know who I am and I
didn't know I had um abilities or gifts
or and some say Talent so for me I
didn't focus on anything apart from
selling drugs and that was it as I got
older I realized I need to ask for help
if I don't know something just ask yeah
that's one thing I'd say to the
youngsters if you're struggling with
anything don't be embarrassed to ask for
help yeah it's probably I didn't
remember some people got pride and some
people you understand and pride is a
thing that a lot of people would
obviously not swallow you know something
just to ask a simple question so I
realized since I come out of jail yeah
I used to have a good lifestyle I used
to have a nice cause nice little chains
and stuff I've let all of that go come
out I drive a little focus on that now
I feel like I've got a weight off my
shoulders like I'm not trying to impress
anyone I'm just being myself now and I'm
enjoying life a whole lot more than I
did when I was a kid
I was arrested for a murder
on a release without charge and went to
a pub in the night time walking back
with a girl
Apparently one of me so God mates phoned
up the shooters and told them which I
was walking and
that's when I got shot 27 times